hello america it's been a long time since i
donned the old secret identity but trust me
it's me homelander now look there's been a little
drama around vaught of lake but i want to reassure
you here and now superheroes are still the good
guys at the end of the day we are tax paying gas
pumping american citizens just like you okay
let's not get carried away because people
they want someone who's stronger and generally
better than them in every single conceivable way
after all who else is going to
save you but don't take it from me
take it from this guy hello america as the
original superhero i assure you that you
are in safe hands with us i'm soldier boy and i
approve this message god bless you soldier boy
translucent blew him up in
the ass man i'm gonna go
so i'm really excited to work with jensen ackles
i've heard wonderful things from eric kripke and
friends who've worked on supernatural it was a
great surprise i found out like everybody else did
you know he dropped the video and the boys account
retweeted it and it just kind of went viral
i think everyone's really excited about jensen
uh joining i i don't know what they're gonna do
with soldier boy because soldier boy in the
comics at least was an older soup i believe
he was the first soup bot ever injected with
compound b so i don't know if that's going to be
a flashback scenario i don't know if it's going
to be like captain america where he was frozen
and now he's thought out i would love to have a
scene with him he seems like a really lovely guy
he's really talented and i think he's perfect
for that captain america escrow and that role
just seems so interesting and nuanced and dark
true to a lot of characters on the boys so i'm
just excited to see what he brings so it'll be
interesting to see uh what storyline he carries
throughout the season and which one of us really
has to go head-to-head with him because usually
there's usually one of us that kind of has a
bone to pick with them you know like frenchie had
lamplighter this season there's going to be some
fun seeing what kind of history we drunk we we
drum up welcome back everyone it's charlie this is
going to be my new video for the boys season three
they just announced a bunch of details about
season three episode one they're dropping all
kinds of promos and teasers for season three
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i will be doing bonus videos for the
boys especially as they start to film season three
episodes i'll number these as we go along just to
stay organized but just starting with the biggest
stuff first we have homelander in the seven doing
a funny promo as a sort of continuation of the
season two ending just reminding everyone of the
lie that the superheroes of vaught are there
to serve the public it's also a bit of a wink
at homelanders trademark phrase when he's with
the people hey you guys are the real heroes they
introduced jensenako's soulja boy character again
who gives his very best captain america sounding
line reading voc gives most of the superheroes
scripts to read from which is why it sounds like
they're all reading from scripts but obviously the
next biggest thing is that season 3 episode 1 is
titled payback which is direct reference to the
payback team in the comics the team this soldier
boy is going to be leading at the beginning of
season 3. if you're not a big boys comic book
reader payback is a direct reference to marvel's
avengers because captain america is kind of like
the leader of the avengers so expect way more
marvel easter eggs but stormfront is also kind of
a reference to thor in the comics also a version
of shazam from dc and the justice league too
pretty much all the major characters on the boys
are parodies of marvel and dc characters either
avengers characters justice league characters
even some of the more minor characters too
within the world of the boys the seven is
meant to be the biggest team though they're
sort of like the a-list team that everybody's
trying to get on so if we're talking like major
league baseball here payback is sort of like the
minor league team that's associated with the seven
like if you're a really powerful really badass
bankable superhero but you're not quite big
enough to make it on the seven at least according
to vots standards they would put you on payback
in fact there weren't a lot of references to this
at the beginning of season two but stormfront also
used to lead the payback team remember stormfront
referenced to thor thor one of the avengers in
the marvel universe but what happens in the comics
is that after stormfront leaves payback basically
their version of captain america soldier boy winds
up taking over the team but the tv show is sort of
mixing and matching things so they might just say
that soldier boy has been the leader of payback
for a long long time but if it wasn't clear vot
sponsors pretty much all the superhero teams
no matter what they do or where they are around
america so when you see them giving them all these
scripts these marching orders all these press
conferences telling them what to do what to say
all these promotional campaigns that they do for
them they do that for all the different superhero
teams it's just that this show has mostly been
focusing on the seven because they're the main
characters of the show but while this is all
going on you also have all this stuff happening
with the payback team jensen acko soldier boy
character and all the other lesser superheroes
they've talked about trying to bring jeffrey
dean morgan on the show they said that there's
a bit of a scheduling problem with the walking
dead because of what the virus has done to
delaying everything so they're trying to get him
on the show for more supernatural easter eggs
he played jensen echo's father on supernatural
eric kripke the showrunner of the boys was also
the creator of the supernatural tv show so they're
trying to bring as many supernatural people onto
the show as possible like they brought bobby
singer from supernatural as a big character during
season two i think his character's name on the
boys was also robert singer just as another even
bigger reference to his supernatural character if
you've seen people asking for them to cast jeffrey
dean morgan as tech night on the show because tech
knight is a big character in the world of the boys
he's sort of their version of batman and iron man
combined the reason why that's also a bit of an
easter egg for payback is because tech knight is
one of the other biggest characters on the payback
team in fact during the boys comic he has a really
hilarious falling out with stormfront in the other
members of the payback team they make a lot of
references to the movies that they make about tech
night's character which is basically a reference
to the marvel movies and the batman movies
but if they wind up announcing his character for
season three then i'll talk more about him there's
just so much that we could talk about so many
problems issues if you think all the stuff that
homelander got up to with the doppelganger and
all the crazy milk during season two is messed
up tech knight is also just as messed up as that
if not more so then the cast during that promo
talks about filming episodes with jensen ackles
and how his soldier boy character is going to
change the dynamic with the seven and also with
the boys like mother's milk says there's always
characters that have bad history with the new
characters they bring on the show like frenchie
had bad history with lamplighter during season two
one of the characters that's most likely to have
bad history with soldier boy because he's so long
lived like stormfront like he's 100 plus years old
would be mallory's character like their history
in the comics they changed the comic book plot for
the tv show quite a bit already in the comics
though mallory is a much older character and
actually fought during world war ii with jensen
ackle's soldier boy character because that's
when he was created mallory's entire company
winds up getting killed because soldier boy
bungles up one of their saves so badly so he
actually winds up killing the original version of
soldier boy during world war ii now obviously the
show has changed that so jensen ackles will be the
same soldier boy from world war ii but also the
one from present day in their version of mallory
is a little bit younger they sort of aged everyone
up so the war that they all make references to
are basically the war in iraq and afghanistan so
just expect them to include some easter eggs for
mallory's history possibly with soldier boy just
because the character has been around for so long
there was also some commentary that the showrunner
posted of this final scene that mallory has with
butcher telling him about all the funding that
he's going to be getting on the dl from victoria
newman so the whole idea now is that they're
actually making the boys team on the show much
more like the comic book version a more legit cia
black ops team that's secretly funded by victoria
newman the very person that huey just went to work
with because he thinks that she's on the up and up
he thinks that he's left the boys to go work
for her because she's this righteous person
doing everything above board the right way and
of course because it's huey that's all going to
blow up in his face metaphorically and literally
make all the jokes you want because she literally
pops heads but i think everything she's up to
is going to be one of the bigger mysteries of
season three what her real backstory is what her
real agenda is i think we all agree that she's had
powers for a long time now but the question now is
what her connection to vaught and stan edgar are
and whether or not her storyline is going to play
out like vic the veep's story line in the comics
that's the character that she's actually based
on she is a comic book character just a slightly
different version then i know there's a bunch of
questions about what's going on with ryan during
season three because they're trying to take him
to a safe house and they still want to try and
raise him the way that his mother was raising him
butcher's wife but everyone just wants to know if
he's gonna grow up really fast if he's gonna
have any big battles with homelander i think
that is the end game making avengers references
because we're talking about marvel and soulja
boy references what is the avengers endgame of the
show obviously it's going to be homelander vs ryan
we made all kinds of star wars darth vader
references talking about stormfront turning
into a cyborg nazi heading into season two but if
we're talking about star wars references i guess
you could call ryan the luke skywalker of the tv
show if homelander is the darth vader the very
bad space dad the other big question too is how is
soldier boy going to threaten homelander because
they keep implying there's going to be some weird
friction between the two of them because soldier
boy is such a popular character but physically
he's not really capable of threatening homeland or
because he's not that powerful what the show has
done is that it's shown homelanders great weakness
is actually more psychological than physical
like maeve is using the footage of the plane to
blackmail him that's how you stop homelander you
can't really stop him physically if he wanted to
kill you he'd kill you in seconds in jensen actual
soldier boy character is also historically one of
the most popular characters within the world
of the boys so in the way early during season
two you see stormfront stealing a lot of attention
from homelander and it just twisting him up inside
just wanting to laser the crap out of her which he
eventually wound up doing i think it's going to be
kind of the same thing with jensen ackle's soldier
boy character just stealing a lot of the thunder
quote-unquote from homelander also if you guys
didn't know they did green light a boys spin-off
tv show about a bunch of college age superheroes
i know people have been asking about the teenage
kicks and a lot of the other characters like
they have the version of the teen titans they
have a version of young avengers within the world
of the boys the way the show runner talks about
it he actually says they're going for a lot more
x-men easter eggs in this spin-off tv show it's
gonna be about a bunch of college kids that are
superheroes at college trying to compete for a
spot on the seven but right now they're getting
ready to film season three episodes release date
maybe by the end of next year if they hustle
really fast the big thing that's coming up
obviously in a couple weeks is the mandalorian
season two so i'll be doing all the episode videos
for that just like i did for season one as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all those videos when i post them there's
going to be a new trailer tonight i will do a
video for that so that will be my next video while
you wait for everything click here for the boys
season 2 episode 8 in all my episode videos and
click here for the mandalorian season 2 trailer
in star wars easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!